speaking of one more year the jury is
still out on whether or not jimmy
garoppolo will have one more year with
the san francisco 49ers a report emerged
over the weekend from mike giardi of nfl
media that the 49ers are looking for a
first-round pick
for jimmy garoppolo well
as many had said in reaction to that
report keep looking because you ain't
going to find it
asking for a first round pick though
could be the precursor to settling for a
two or three or whatever you can get but
you got to start somewhere you got to
make it known this is what we want and
hey if there is some sort of a fluke
injury suffered by a quarterback during
training camp like teddy bridgewater
five years ago maybe you do get a first
first-round pick for jimmy garoppolo but
at least you put that price tag you put
the retail price on him for a while and
then you worry about discounting it
later chris yeah right i mean yes
there's no doubt i mean i first off like
i agree with your first statement there
there's no way they're getting a
first-round pick for jimmy garoppolo
unless they've become some you know
maybe they could get a few teams bidding
after him but i still don't think that's
that's not realistic you know maybe the
scenario you're talking about where it's
okay let's keep them through you know
training camp and maybe a team does have
a desperate teddy bridgewater like
situation all right then you get rid of
them but what if that doesn't happen you
know what if that doesn't happen now
now i mean you're going to go into the
year with him there
and even though you know it's like hey
we kind of you know we wanted to trade
you you're here with us and all that i
don't know or they just cut them and
they get nothing for them so i think
like you're right with what your thought
is is it's an asking price here it
starts here i just don't think it's not
even realistic to think that the first
round pick is going to happen for jimmy
garoppolo not when there's been 9 000
you know
red flares shot up into the sky out of
san francisco to go we want another
quarterback we want another quarterback
we want another quarterback so everybody
knows
you know that there's some sort of sense
in san francisco that they're trying to
get rid of jimmy g whether it's now
after the year whatever that is and i
just don't think they're going to get
the price that of course we're hearing
about right now
yeah first round pick is going to be way
too much especially when you have to
deal with his contract 25 million
dollars in total compensation due this
year but again
price tag it's a price tag you hang on
him
and and maybe there's
desperation somewhere somehow
that triggers the kind of offer that is
close to a first-round pick or could
become a first-round pick well because
this is the kind of trade that gets made
maybe after the draft and it's
conditional first-rounder next year if
he plays at least 14 games if the team
makes the playoffs it goes from a three
to one and i know teams don't like to
tie up that many potential draft picks
because then if you have a three or a
two or a one that it can eventually be
you can't do anything with those three
picks later in the year you got to wait
and see what happens but still something
like that would be fair if it's post
2021 draft going into 2022 a conditional
pick based upon how much he plays yeah
and how well the team does but i still
think desperation is what's going to
trigger the market a team that thinks
maybe they're going to get a first round
quarterback that they like and they
don't right or
the texans end up in a tail spin and
they don't know what to do and deshawn
watson's gone and then they're not
thrilled with the idea of tyrod taylor
being the starter so they go get someone
that nick casario knows
who knows there's all sorts of of ways
that desperation can emerge but i think
that's the best way for the 49ers to get
any real value for jimmy garoppolo
someone else has to be sufficiently
desperate like the vikings were
extremely desperate late august early
september of 2016 to give the eagles a
first round pick and a fourth round pick
for sam bradford so the eagles could go
with carson wentz right out of the gates
as a rookie and and also to add to that
minnesota was in the window of like
thinking hey we're kind of a super bowl
team here so we're really desperate like
we we don't have a quarterback we need
somebody that can get us there i mean i
think that was all part of that you know
that's that that was a special formula
to make that happen
you know but i mean again i i just can't
think of too many scenarios that are
like this to where
you know a team did get a first round
for this caliber of player who's not
always available like you're talking
about where we know the team is looking
you know
for other options at the position
all of those things i mean this they
they've lowered the value of what that
trade is that that's the big thing i
think i come to and then here the other
aspect i think that you know the 49ers
will at least have to think about here
as far as like what you're talking about
keeping teams desperate or the market
high or whatever because i'm with you i
think like ultimately it could be like a
third round pick with like hey he played
14 of the 16 games and now it becomes a
second round pick i think that's more
like in line of what i would think it is
but
i think you also got to keep track keep
tr uh keep track of the the current
market that's out there right now what's
going on
i mean i would think
at some point here over the next three
to four weeks too all right jimmy
garoppolo available for trade i would
think there's a good chance sam
darnold's gonna become available for
trade that's not gonna help out the
jimmy garoppolo trade market not at this
point right now i mean that's one other
seat that can be filled by
i think a quarterback that teams are
going to look at and go he's a starter
he can play for us we can go to the
playoffs with that guy
so that element's in there too that's
where the 49ers they're gonna have to be
smart without how they played this you
know yeah you want to get teams and you
want to get the ultimate you know price
tag for the trade but at the same time
you don't want to be so stubborn that
you leave yourself out in the you know
out in the cold out in the dark with no
business or nobody to talk to as far as
getting the trade because you know you
you drew such a line in the sand for
such a high price that they that other
teams went other places to get a
quarterback
who's worth more there are the numbers
yeah darnold or garoppolo who gets more
in a trade
i i would um that's a really good one i
would think darnold would i would yeah
i just think with darnold
still like
early in his career i think there's been
enough on film out there you're going to
watch it and you're going man there's a
lot to like
you know and and i think a really good
football person is going to realize too
he's been in a tough situation
there's no doubt i mean for me sam
darnold is clearly the more talented
football player than jimmy garoppolo uh
so i would think he could maybe you know
ask for a hair more in the trade market
than jimmy g could at this point
other side of that coin as well and
point is the operative word here sam
darnold under a much lower salary this
year than garoppolo garoppolo's at 25
million donald's in the fourth year of a
slotted rookie contract that doesn't pay
out significant salary but
whoever has him under contract has until
may 3rd to decide whether or not to pick
up the option on 2022 and for the first
time
that option fifth year for a first round
quarterback is not guaranteed for injury
only it's fully guaranteed it's going to
be about 20 million dollars for sam
darnold so you got to be ready to make
that decision if he's under contract
with your team right i don't think the
jets if they keep him pick up the option
if you trade him how do you not pick up
the option if you give up a second round
pick right
you're picking up the guy for one year
and you're gonna roll the dice although
we've seen that we've seen that dice
roll before we saw it most recently with
uh mitch trubisky in chicago where the
bears kept him for that final year and
you know hey if he has a great year then
we got to deal with it well he didn't
and he walks away and they weren't on
the hook for the potential fifth year
option
which was injury guaranteed the stakes
are raised now because the guy's getting
the money one way or the other so that
becomes a factor in this as well but
look as this quarterback musical chairs
has moved throughout the past month or
so there aren't many left no uh barring
a trade of a russell wilson or whatever
it is that's going to happen with the
sean watson we'll be talking about him
later in the hour that there aren't many
guys left
carolina and denver i mean
right there aren't many seats and there
aren't many guys right
right so it's carolina and denver i
think we look at as two teams that are
probably still out there on the market
you know yeah minus like you're talking
about houston seattle those are weird
situations don't know how to go but just
teams we know that are looking right now
to go we need to either bring somebody
in to compete or be our starter or
whatever else
i mean that that's the only two we're
really looking at right i think it's i
think that's it i mean and
yeah what and you're right no but and if
and we look at the board right if we
assume it's lawrence trevor lawrence to
jacksonville zach wilson right the jets
someone else at quarterback to the 49ers
let's just say for the sake of argument
mac jones you've been hearing trey lance
possibly to the falcons that leaves
justin fields for the panthers or the
broncos
that means one of them's not gonna get a
guy in the top ten right and that team
may pivot to
donald
or garoppolo
at that point yeah but but but beyond
that there aren't many guys and there
aren't many spots
and and that's where this gets
interesting but for now the 49ers don't
have to rush i think you let it play out
you get through the first round of the
draft
and see
who's still
looking around for a quarterback option
better than the guy they currently have
and that may be the way that they could
get something
mustard now
or they can keep keep waiting you're
taking the risk
chris if you like garoppolo go
you're assuming
that the guy you draft at three is going
to be ready to go yeah week one and you
don't have garoppolo's insurance against
that yeah i know that that's that's
where attention that's where i don't
know what to think with the 49ers what
they're doing it's also the reason why i
think it is mac jones okay yeah i mean
we've talked about it yeah of course i
know my friend and all those type of
things but i just think it makes the
most sense from that standpoint too a
team that's kind of ready with a
quarterback that's
nfl pro ready
right away instead of
you know okay what we get a fields or a
lance who
uh as you've heard me say i think need a
little i think there's a lot of people
that think you know there's they might
need a year or they need some work or
whatever that so now you're gonna keep
jimmy g
and then i just again i think it's a
great risk because it's like okay yeah
we kept jimmy g and here we are we're 12
and four with jimmy g our team was
really good he didn't have that great of
a year but we're 12-4 and he did good
enough and watch out you know that i
mean that to me puts you puts you in a
really tough spot as an organization so
uh we'll see 49ers got some tough
decisions to make and they're gonna have
to figure this out
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports